nicole
starts us off this hour in spokane
washington hi nicole how are you
i'm good thank you um my husband and i
have a question about whether or not
it is wise to consider him making his
side work his full-time work
or if like some of our family think that
might be
risky to leave his secure
government job to do that security is an
illusion okay
right so what's he making what's he
making on his side gig
um on a good year when he works a lot
it's about fifteen thousand a year
and what does he make at his good secure
government job
just over uh take home pays about fifty
thousand a year
okay what is the side gig um
remodel repair construction general
contractor
so he's not doing much of it well he
does
he not much he made 15 000. he should
have made 50 000.
well he does time and materials and
that's part of it is it's
this balance between not having enough
time to take on the big jobs
and whether or not it's nope um nope you
can take on a bunch of little jobs
he hadn't taken on enough of those yet
so here's the thing a buddy of mine that
does renovations
made 300 grand last year he has two
employees
okay this is your husband's future
right that's what i want him to do i
want to make 300 000 and so
he can look at your relatives and go
i got your security right here you know
right so uh
because that's what he needs to do okay
but now we've got to get there wisely
jumping from 50 to 15 on a hope and a
prayer and i could take the big jobs
won't work okay
yeah so how do we do that we got to get
the boat closer to the dock before we
jump you're going to miss the boat
and land in the water so we're going to
work this year
like maniacs doing a bazillion little
small
jobs all of them at time of materials
price profit or profit margin i don't
care get better at estimating and deal
with it
but get your dadgum net profit up to
forty five thousand dollars and then
quit the government job
and the next year make ninety
well that sounds like a great plan it's
not a great plan because this year's
gonna be hell
he's gonna work 80 and 90 hour weeks for
a year
okay he's got two full-time jobs
yeah but you've got to prove it to
yourself
and to your wife or if it's the other
way around to your husband
that this is real because you can't go i
you cannot bet on a wing and a prayer
that i think i can feed my family from
50 to 15. that's too big a jump
you got to get the boat closer do you
see what i'm saying
yeah and when you get ready to quit and
you're tired and worn out and you made
45 000
you know you can make 90. but right now
you think you might make 90.
right there's a difference that's how i
would do it if i were in your shoes
and then i would uh quit the secure
government job and be in the secure
construction business because i got to
tell you man renovations
and repairs if you show up on time
you do good work you keep your word and
you keep your price intact
you will have more work because nobody
does that in that business
you you have no competition you have
more work than you'll know what to do
with you'll be
absolutely swamped that's what happened
to my buddy because everybody
you know they they want to leave at 2 30
on friday
and go sit on their butt and drink beer
instead of getting their dad gum work
done
and the jobs have finished and the
homeowner's crying and
the homeowner's husband or wife's
bitching at him because the thing ain't
done
if you're not that guy you can get rich
in the construction business
i just now stepped out during the break
called my wife and said
is everything squared up at the house
somebody's supposed to take care of it
and she said nope i'm going to do
laundry at a friend's house because they
had a flat tire and they're going to
have to maybe come tomorrow or the next
it's just the nature of that business
it's the middle of the freaking day
just show you get over there and you fix
the stuff
fix it man oh my god this is why is this
hard
i don't know man and then they you know
then when they go broke they'll go well
the economy got me it was covered
no it's your lazy coveted butt is what
it was oh my god that drives me bananas
can you imagine if i called in and said
hey dave i'm gonna miss the radio show i
got a flat tire
um i'm squared up i'll holler back hitch
no i can't you know what you could
imagine that and then you would say
just yeah your tires are gonna be flat
for a while just don't cover
uber get your butt over here call
somebody fix your tires
we have stuff to do god almighty
okay now i guess yeah but i'm telling
you the construction i grew up in the
real estate and construction business
and i and i'm not mad at construction
people they're not all that way
but i'm just telling you they're just
tell the truth and show up you can
make so much money because all you got
to do is
my son we were doing a renovation on our
house daniel was 14 years old
we're driving along i know exactly where
we're because i kind of panicked
we pulled up at a stop sign because we
i've been dealing with this
person working on our house
[Laughter]
and i pull it up a stop sign daniel says
dad i know what i'm gonna do when i grow
up and i'm going oh well this is
revelation that's cool what are you
gonna do
he goes i'm going in the construction
business
[Laughter]
what he goes well it's easy so what do
you mean it's easy he goes
all you gotta do is do what you said you
were gonna do tada
and you won't have any competition and i
went you're 14
and you get this hey you know what
that's kind of the secret to all of life
yeah if you just show up and be a good
person and do what you say you're gonna
do
yeah if you work hard and tell the truth
you beat 80 percent of the people
because they people eighty percent of
people cannot do those two things and
then if you do good work on top of
working hard
oh that's the other twenty man you can
charge anything
you just what's the estimate okay do it
yeah because i can you know this is
yeah you charged me what okay that's
okay it got done yeah
i didn't have a flat tire nicole
just tell him to show up and do good
work yeah he's gonna be fine but you got
to prove yourself
15 000 is too big a jump okay so get
your income up
and then go do it and your relatives
don't understand my grandmother was the
sweetest i love my grandmother more than
anything in the world
her husband my grandpa lost a business
in the great depression worked 38 years
for alcoa aluminum
one job because it was secure and i'll
never forget
we were had this business running and i
just sold financial piece to the
publisher for
zeros on the end of the decimal right
and i sat down with she said honey i
hope all this stuff works out when are
you going to get a real job
[Laughter]
when are you going to get a real job
there's that is just it because to her i
didn't have a real job i was
i was working for myself which means i
couldn't have got a job apparently right
so uh i wasn't employable that's why i
was working for myself
i love girls there's probably some truth
to that
i hear me better than i like to admit
they love us